I'm in the game I'm in the gang I'm in
the gang I'm in the game I'm in a game I
am in a gang
where you grew up at quiz oh New York
yeah where you from
Queens like any names
97th Street okay how about you my man
these Dino we're at guthrus okay
watching San Gabriel Valley I grew up in
West L.A from Playboys gang okay where
are you from okay go ahead
Elm Street power okay okay well that's
what I asked you where you from but you
told me Chris I'm asking where you from
we've here find out who's from the hood
where you from huh again East 16th new
Kirk okay okay I'm gonna call my people
real quick
jail system Mother where you at you ever
been to jail I was in the feds then in
the states so the federal game is
totally different so I was in MDC
Brooklyn right and MCC Manhattan which
is for a federal pre-trial I did a few
years of the juvenile in three years in
the fast all right you win man no not
locked up no time at all how about you
I've been away I know this way it was at
srcc first got out after that 67 days
did uh what eight years and some change
they gave me 10 85 percent as an adult
too huh well me no I I miss why I went
from Camp to after that to prison saying
cleaning what level were you in oh two
so how do they jump you guys in your
hood over there where you're at from are
they coaching the neighborhood I didn't
get involved fully into getting stuff
until I went into MDC Brooklyn a guy
jumps in and you know what man I jumped
in you jumped in how many guys well five
what they call them remember no the guys
that jumped you in oh homies but with
the homies names I remember the homies
jump in the homie Chapel the homie
Sinbad the homie trouble all right
somebody beats you up you kind of
remember who beats you up all right the
homie day is homie Big Mike and then
other nickel you know okay how old are
you 36. and you say you've never been to
jail no man I'm beyond I wasn't even in
their life like that man I was in to get
money me too I'm all about money but I
still end up getting caught so who
jumped in the Playboys hey you took me
way back
lazy lucky grumpy baby tear and munchie
chew
that's right well so far if I was to
think I'm thinking these two guys
somewhere over here I don't know why I
just can't figure out which one it is
man so we didn't ask him no questions
you know what I I started banging in
1989 North Hollywood California 91606
I'm from Hollywood boys they called me
stranger I ended up going to Hawaii 91 I
got committed for busting some cops my
wife number six three two nine eight I
did about six years I lived through the
whole 90s gang banging and uh yeah and
now I'm here just you know share my
story and kind of change the the way I
changed my life that's what it's for and
it's very cool to sit here and try to
guess who was that person you know so
that's what that's what I'm here for
he's just his demeanor seemed like like
a cop to me like he has put on that
sheriff certainly like yo get against
the car how long did you get jumped in
for it wasn't so much a time because
someone said oh 13 because out here
south but mine wasn't one of those man
I'm glad we had to get jumped in on my
family for my neighborhoods or you know
oh so you just yeah when you get jumped
in I didn't have to yeah
let me ask you guys one thing real quick
because touching what you were saying a
lot of people always say especially when
you're young you knew what you signed up
for and you signed up for the gang did
you know what you were signing up for
absolutely not no I was told yeah
sometimes you don't understand when
you're young like being told but
understanding is a different thing yeah
for me like I was definitely told mine
didn't do that exactly you're like oh
you want to be from the set oh here you
go this right here they did what to your
brother go do that they didn't tell me
about me growing up in life I'm gonna
get shot back in return I've been shot
nine times different occasions ran over
twice one was accident one wasn't
that's not no life hey I'm Cole and I
directed this episode of odd one out if
you like this episode and you want to
see more like this subscribe to our
Channel
[Music]
you grew up in the streets if you'd have
been in jail from a juvenile to an adult
so when he said no he never been to jail
oh no
we're Southsiders so we're 13 seconds
and when he said that he didn't have the
13 seconds it just sounded a little off
I've never been to jail I have been
arrested a bunch of times but um never
I've never been charged or anything you
have any tattoos of course I do I just
can't show you man the feathers are
watching
[Laughter]
I'm scared of the fish oh man you better
be scared of the fans because they're
gonna get you I wanna know what that
tattoo is right there on your hand
which one that one right there you know
which one I'm talking about
Castle it's a crown does it mean
anything
it's a crown there you go so you did fed
time yes well what gang were you from
again ITF two okay he had full-blown
like hanyas and and like Japanese art
I've never seen no Hispanics with
dragons and stuff like that you know
what I mean I just kind of threw me off
a little how many different sets of
playboys is there what do you mean by
sets clicks or clicks and what click are
you from the actual you guys actually
have also like a click click because
click to me is is you could be from the
hood where you get from the locals the
Winos you know I know a little bit about
gangster just a little bit
maybe a car who knows
um what click were you from because you
didn't you didn't let me finish okay
no he didn't let me finish Crystal
bunnies Crystal bunnies yeah
ew
[Laughter]
first tattoo I got was in uh when I get
my first tattoo man
first tattoo was in my stomach was my
homie did it my homochuko did it busted
out the old uh piano thing on
the on the gun and doesn't look hot
whatsoever I was about 14 15 years old
so go what organization are you with
organization as far as what like gang oh
I never heard it that way yeah
very simple I mean I grew up on Sierra
stream from Tierra Street locals you'll
still find me on the Block drinking the
beer with the homies every once in a
while but in a positive way where I'm
actually trying to school them and tell
me listen brother there ain't no future
in this like I want the little homies to
look at me to say I want to be like
stranger he owns his own home he's
married taking care of his kids working
and showing the kids how to you know
it's a better way what do you do for
what do you work structural concrete I'm
a tournament plumber Union okay that's
what's up I try to tell everybody to
join like because I'm in the 50s getting
paid I do illegal activities
a caregiver so I go to prisons and and
speak I do like Christian content
creation too I mentioned I own a bunch
of companies my main business is dealer
Synergy a lot of clients are big car
dealerships all over the United States
so I do like sales training Consulting
Business Development I've helped these
companies make over 1.5 billion dollars
in additional Revenue I'm also a
professional speaker in the National
Speakers Association and I wrote a book
about Google so I'd say it's hard to
classify I mean more than anything else
I'm an entrepreneur invest in businesses
how long you've been speaking at prisons
and stuff I've been doing this since
2016. how did you get clearance for that
weren't you busted before how much are
off and you get your stuff right you can
do that because I got another I know
another person to do it been to prison
but now he go to the prison
yeah if he really does it I got a
question for you um you live out in L.A
or no no I flew in for the show I live
in South Jersey and Medford New Jersey
oh because I don't hear an accident or
I'm 46 I work my ass off to get rid of
my accident yeah good job it gets rid of
their accident why do you get rid of
your accent homes are you kidding me
it's already bad enough you know I mean
people are judging you and like
that so you got to turn around and you
gotta look the poor feel the port if
you're trying to turn around and how do
you say water bro water water
um I had a question about were you
talking about tattoos um you your first
tattoo was made with a homemade gun yeah
the homemade gun with what did it was a
guitar string oh I used to be pianos
like no no we don't we can't afford them
yeah
Charlie Holmes busted out the older
piano thing guitar maybe I said
piano man I'm sticking a guitar right
now I'm so curious why I want to show
the tattoos
he just did it seem Thug daddy seemed a
little polished no disrespect I'm not
saying it was softer like that but he
just did not scream like thug and Thug
I'm a little bit uh a little bit miffed
that I got voted off but it's all good
my story is just kind of crazy you know
I mean so it might have sounded like it
was a plant and I knew that coming in it
was either a double-edged sword this
other Fez you you salute to me too I'm
putting that wire on that's how you do
it Playboy
you can't be joking a little too much
huh
raise your hand if you want me you want
to keep playing because people are still
in there
who some of your homies did anybody do
time in Ironwood I don't know they were
homies as a homies all in prison so I
can't tell you who in that one you only
spent time in prison once or twice how
much how many years two two at what
percent does he give you what you mean
what percent it was halftime
okay what did you get busted for you
know be on probation you get car work
done violation and you're in a level two
yeah for a firearm
like that because that ain't my points
wasn't High finish the sentence for me
all right the higher the socks
the only one right here I'll be straight
on is would be her right now
yeah these two guys I'm sure from the
hood you could be you could be you could
be nine yeah I know you think I'm not
from the hood but I am from the hood so
it kind of this thing really makes it
interesting that's the only reason why I
kept playing right that's exactly what
Gil said because I'm not willing to take
the chance homie
and that's no disrespect that's no
disrespect she's the mom there's just
ain't quiet over there
it in nobody never been shot I'm the
only person I've been shot how many
times you get shot no different
occasions five man first time I got shot
was five times two times right here in
the shoulder one inside the face and one
on this side of my buttocks and it came
out over here when I got shot on the AK
with another time two times on this side
and this line then I got shot by some of
your people oh yeah it's amazing they
didn't have and if they were trying to
shoot me though they were shooting they
would shoot out some other Asians so my
homeboys with security guards at the
club in West Ministry we black we being
nosy peeking out there man they one of
us to put out a gun out the shooting the
bullet came through the door hit me
right in this leg I fell to the ground
was so funny I'm like oh I'm here my
homeboy started laughing like we called
my mama like oh your son got shot first
thing she said is my car okay because
I've been shot again but it was funny
though it's kind of amazing how we could
talk about some guy getting shot nine
times and be like you know not Shalom
but hope for the future Generations
don't don't have those kind of
conversations as much anymore man I try
to talk to him and tell them yeah tell
my little homies all the time man like
you guys don't want to live this way but
they think it's cool though right I tell
them you can live like a dope dealer you
don't got to be a doctor yeah
you can live like a you know
I'm really looking at his tattoos and
thinking does he have fake tattoos they
put some movie star type tattoos on them
and I voted for him that time around
sorry Madball
you know I just didn't trust him
and that's no disrespect there was a tie
kill and Madball one minute to just
pitch why do you think you're not the
mole I actually have a YouTube platform
called American child on why because I
lived the troll life to the fullest the
last 20 years I've been living that
American life to the fullest that way I
pushed American troll that's the way I
speak the way I speak and and maybe not
sound like as your typical trollo but if
you guys don't think I'm the cholo
that's actually a good thing because I'm
breaking The Stereotype there well me
y'all could probably hear my voice do I
sound like a square person you know you
look at me or the average I might scare
you on the streets if you don't know me
like
oh no I'm just like no I could never be
a mo I don't believe in snitches
you guys actually escort Madball and
Guild to the green
it's a blind broke it's a blind so why I
think it's Madball I said what what how
much percent and then he goes what you
mean yeah and I was like and he goes
half time after like yeah
the San Quinn level two look I was
locked up when I caught my my gun charge
too and I I didn't I never went to level
two I always went to level three no I
agree I agree for sure
bring them in
oh look at that man
I'm about to cry
away
I'm like oh I know they're gonna get
guilt for sure he's out of here I wasn't
expecting me please raise your hand on
three mini you want to continue playing
one two three
okay
if the Box turns red
that means real gang members have lost
and that the mole is still in the box
and they win the cash prize for
themselves if the Box turns green that
means you three split the cash prize and
you've correctly guessed what it really
is
you ready
yeah let's go
[Music]
on the count of three the mole can stand
up okay one
two
three
[Music]
ever been in jail I went to jail a lot
of my homeboys did it I was around it so
if I really wanted to I could have but
reason why I didn't gain bangs because
my family made sure I didn't gang bang I
just stayed away from it pretty much
that's good you made the right choice
but man you made the right choice I
thought I was a little nervous about
this because I had to sit there and lie
the actual gang members when I see a
person these young kids running around
like going crazy I don't really judge
them because I was one of those kids you
know and if I had somebody like me I
feel like back then I don't think I
would have lived even half as miserable
as I did someone like me an ex-gang
number ex-convict X piece of
has a shot at that American Dream as
long as there's breath in our lungs we
have an opportunity to change there's
always a second chance and I'm just
hoping to give a young person that uh
that hope that he can change his life
and hopefully will
all right
this is a lot of cash it is
foreign